most Americans think that marijuana
should be legal and Donald Trump
campaigned on being the administration
of the people but the Trump
administration will soon start cracking
down on recreational marijuana ramping
up the embarrassing pathetic retrograde
counterproductive war on drugs eight
states currently plus DC have
effectively legalized marijuana 17
states have introduced legislation to do
the same thing the policy of the Obama
Justice Department was marijuana still
illegal federally but we're not going to
interfere with states who have made
their own laws to legalized or
decriminalized but that was just a memo
it doesn't really have legal power it
could easily be undone by new reefer
madness Attorney General Jeff Sessions
who has consistently opposed marijuana
and cheered the war on drugs Sean Spicer
talking about marijuana at a recent
press conference says that decisions
from the DOJ and law enforcement about
the enforcement of federal marijuana
laws could change here's Sean Spicer
take a listen to this I do believe that
you'll see greater enforcement of it
because again there's a big difference
between the medical use which Congress
has through an appropriations rider in
2014 made very clear what the intent of
what what their intent was in terms of
how the Department of Justice would
handle that issue that's very different
than the recreational use which is
something that the Department of Justice
I think will be further looking into yes
further looking into once he started
being asked more questions including by
Glen thrush from the New York Times
started being evasive and we know
exactly the direction that it's going
recall that the guy in charge now jeff
sessions said he was okay with the Ku
Klux Klan until he found out that they
smoked weed said you can't be a good
person
if you smoke pot the Trump campaign and
administration constantly talk about
we're gonna honor states rights what
happened to that states rights is a joke
for Republicans it's only when they like
it states rights to ban abortion get rid
of roe v wade that's great states right
to ban gay marriage cancel out the
Supreme Court decision that sounds great
states rights to hand out guns like
candy no restrictions
hey get rid of those federal gun laws
states want to legalize marijuana whoa
whoa whoa Pat what about the federal
government's power all of a sudden
yeah and it's one of those things where
they can kind of just do on their own
they don't have to go through Congress
at all because it is existing law and of
course federal law trumps state law the
Supremacy Clause Trump's 4mc clause and
also yeah that's a good point I feel
like I threw you off with that yeah
there's a there's a lot actually that
could be done is the truth people saying
well Obama wrote the memo but actually
the Justice Department can get US
attorneys to send threatening letters to
marijuana businesses saying hey you're
breaking federal law they could file
lawsuits against States because again
marijuana is illegal by federal law and
the worst nightmare would be DEA raids
start up in the states that have
legalized marijuana and the thing is
when you think of the the coalition that
elected Trump I mean it's a vastly
diverse group of people but some of
those folks are these libertarian
small-government types they're going to
be very upset if these pot shops start
getting cracked down upon by the Trump
administration and they're probably
going to end up regretting their vote
for Trump if they chose to do that yeah
and his approval rating would continue
to go down and I like how you say that a
diverse coalition voted for Trump that's
true just not diverse in the sense we
normally think of as diverse but yeah
libertarians disaffected independents
the religious right absolute low
information lunatic grifters the
pro-business Republicans it was a
coalition in that sense but didn't
really include some of what we would
normally consider it was not racial
diversity it's not racial diversity
that's for sure and of course the
Republicans against small government
when it's about not regulate not
regulating businesses or letting people
have their armed militias or not funding
social programs but all of a sudden when
it's marijuana raids or defense spending
or whatever small government goes away
for right-wingers so we will be
following it and by the way same day
that this was announced the US
government is going to be restarting
some of their contracts for federal
private prisons you'll remember under
Obama big announcement
no more federal contracts with private
prisons of course very few people are
actually
in federal private prisons doesn't
matter slowly sort of eroded and now at
the same time that was hearing that
there may be a crackdown on marijuana we
see new contracts with federal private
prisons probably not a coincidence is it
well yeah it makes sense if you're
arresting more people for marijuana for
selling it or even using it you're gonna
have to put more people in jail and that
kind of helps the prison industrial
complex and Bernie Sanders tweeting
about this very very much against what's
going on he sent a couple of tweets
about this one saying private prison
companies invested hundreds of thousands
of dollars in Trump's campaign and today
they got their reward also tweeting
Trump just opened the floodgates for
private prisons to make huge profits by
building more prisons and keeping even
more Americans in jail indeed discuss
this with us on Reddit we are on reddit
at david pakman.com slash re d di t
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS